philippe de veules avocat philippe de
veules merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france votre réaction pour
commencer que vous inspire ce projet de
loi eh bien je pense que ce projet de
loi
je pense même que c'est plutôt de
composition puisqu'il émane de député je
crois qu'elle est contre productive
parce que les forces de l'ordre sont
dépositaires de l'autorité publique ils
disposent de la violence légitime et
dans ce cadre ils n'ont rien à cacher de
dire ce qui se cache sont plutôt les
bandits des les voleurs qui veulent le
dissimuler des preuves
or dans une police républicaine il doit
pas y avoir ce genre de comportement
déjà dans les forces spéciales labeyrie
dans les interventions terroristes les
fonctionnaires des forces de l'ordre ont
des cagoules pour protéger leur identité
et c'est déjà très bien
donc ya pas besoin de légiférer en plus
selon vous est ce que cette proposition
de loi est une atteinte à la liberté
d'informer et qu'est ce qui caractérise
cette atteinte dans ce cas là la
manifestation de la vérité parce que
vous savez très bien qu'ils aient
beaucoup de violence d'êta dans les
manifestations dans la contestation
populaire depuis depuis le 17 novembre
2018 et qu'il ya beaucoup de d'un terne
en suspens certaines ont été jugées
comme la sphère d'une manifestante giflé
le 1er mai où le fonctionnaire défense
de l'ordre étaient jugés et je crois
qu'il ya même un appel où il était
condamné
donc on ne sait pas parce qu'on est
dépositaire de l'autorité publique que
tout est permis
on est on est soumis à des lois et c'est
ça ce que je connais avec cette loi
c'est que c'est en fin de compte c'est
ça veut dire que les policiers pourront
désormais agir en toute impunité et déjà
on voit bien que dans ces unités
particulière qui avait été dissoute en
86 la brave qui dispose de moto un
conducteur et un fonctionnaire qui est
derrière avec une matraque et du gaz est
une arme et bien sont déjà masqué ne
voit pas le visage et ils n'ont pas pas
et n'ont parfois pas l'or et rio l'an
numéro d'immatriculation
donc moi je pense et je suis pas du tout
je n'ai pas là un langage contre
lecompte les fonctionnaires de forces de
l'ordre ayant su prêt à défendre un
fonctionnaire dépens de l'or qui qui
seraient victimes d'une injustice dans
le cadre de ses fonctions
mais je pense que dans un pays comme le
nôtre attachés à ces libertés publiques
attaché à son droit
il doit y avoir une transparence sur
l'identité des policiers surtout dans le
maintien de l'ordre
maintenant après quand il s'agit
d'opérations spéciales en matière de
terrorisme ça je comprends tout à fait
l'anonymat alors ce projet de loi évoque
également le développement d'un policier
bashing en une stigmatisation des forces
de l'ordre dans la société française est
ce que c'est le cas selon vous
aujourd'hui et comment y remédier oui
tout à fait il ya en fin de compte une
guerre des images qu'on voit au niveau
d'interpellations divers et variés des
fonctionnaires des forces de l'ordre
il faut pas cacher que des
subissent d etde des insultes des
injures des actes violents comme
certains fonctionnaires des forces de
l'ordre violent la viole leur
déontologie
donc je pense qu'il faut recentrer et
apaiser les choses et je crois qu'on fin
de compte ça s'est exacerbée avec le
l'utilisation l'utilisation des forces
de l'ordre dans les manifestations comme
commune une forme de police politique
à force de verbalisation de
d'interpellation de gardes à vue
abusives
parce que j'ai défendu beaucoup de
manifestants je peux vous dire que
beaucoup de ces gardes à vue ont terminé
avec des classements sans suite ou de
simple rappel à la loi
donc il ya eu une utilisation
disproportionnée des forces de l'ordre
dans une question politique dans une
question qui concerne en fin de compte
une question sociale et qui n'est pas en
fin de compte traiter par la bonne voie
pour conclure peut-être cette dernière
question aujourd'hui si un membre des
forces de l'ordre ne souhaite pas être
filmés sur la voie publique pour pour
différentes raisons à ce qu'il y a des
dispositions légales qui lui permet de
faire respecter ce soit eux ou alors ça
fait partie justement deux îles et il
fait partie du paysage publique un
fonctionnaire des forces de l'ordre d'un
parloir comme comme un avocat vous savez
que nous nous sommes victimes nos
exercer une activité publique
nos adresses sont connus nos identités
sont connus et ça n'empêche pas qu'on
reçoit des menaces diverses et variées
mais un fonctionnaire défense de l'ordre
est un personnage public appartient à la
vie publique et donc il n'a pas caché
dissimulé son visage c'est cesser je
pense que cette ces lois sont sont un
peu mettre de l'huile sur le sur le
sujet et je crois que à mon avis un
homme politique sérieux qui aimerait
justement avoir une bonne police devrait
regarder justement la manifestation de
la liberté 2 2 de la vérité est d'avoir
une application de la justice rapide et
immédiate justement lorsqu'un
fonctionnaire contrevient à la loi
maintenant il s'agit de dire que les
fois les forces de l'ordre sont
généralement peu de bonne de deux
confessions air et que c'est vraiment
une minorité qui peut être amenée à des
contestations mais dans l'est dans les
manifestations n'a pu s'apercevoir quand
même qu'il y avait une sorte de
couverture de la part du ministre
l'intérieur sur les agissements de
certains fonctionnaires des forces de
l'ordre et je serai et je dirais pour
conclure c'est que la police doit être
sans peur et sans reproche
tél l'image du chevalier bayard merci
beaucoup philippe dauvel rappelle que
vous êtes avocat